Knitting ribbing or adding both knit
and Pearl stitches to your knitting
without a ribber means you
have to reform stitches.
Now, that doesn't mean that you have
to just do boring ribbing,
one by one or two by two ribbing.
You can get very decorative
ribbing techniques on the ribber.
Now, this is a pretty cabled pattern,
cabled ribbing pattern,
that's done completely on the machine.
To work this pretty cable pattern,
it's just a two by two rib
or knit two, Pearl two rib.
You'll cast on and knit two rows.
Now, set up your two by two ribbing
and then do a cable cross
on the opposite stitches.
So for example, we've got knit and Pearl
stitches, every two row stitches here,
and on the Pearl stitch as they're
facing us will cross a single stitch.
Now, knit two rows again,
reform those two stitches,
and create knit stitches
as they're facing you.
Do your cable cross again, knit two rows,
and repeat for the length of your ribbing.
So you're stopping every other row,
crossing your cables
and reforming your stitches.
Now, try this technique because you'll
need to get into a rhythm
to create this stitch pattern.
If your yarn is really slippery or you're
creating a really wide ribbing,
you might want to only knit the two rows,
do your cable cross, reform your stitches,
knit two rows,
do your cable cross, reform the stitches.
If you also prefer, you can do your cable
crosses and reform all
the stitches at the same time.
A rhythm that you need
to set up for yourself.
Try this technique just over a small
swatch, and you'll see what
beautiful ribbing you can create.